Profª. Tamar Gendler: Eu quero
começar hoje seguindo
do ponto que paramos na aula anterior.
Nós falávamos, no contexto da
obra de Jonathan Shay,
Achilles In Vietnam,
sobre os prejuízos que
parecem envolver as pessoas
que se encontram em
condições de um
comportamento
que acreditam ser imoral ou injusto.
Pois em 1961, nos jornais de
toda a área de New Haven,
foi posto o seguinte anúncio.
Dizia: "Anúncio público.
Vamos pagar-lhe US$ 4 – isso era
uma boa quantia na época –
por 1 hora do seu tempo.
Precisamos de pessoas para
estudo de memória.
Pagaremos 500 homens para nos ajudar
a concluir um estudo científico de
memória e aprendizagem.
O estudo será feito na
Universidade de Yale.
Cada participante receberá US$ 4,
mais US$ 0,50 em transporte,
por um tempo aproximado de 1 hora.
Precisamos de você por apenas 1 hora.
Não existem outras obrigações.
Você pode escolher o
horário que lhe convém:
noites, fins de semana ou
durante a semana."
E o anúncio continuava dizendo
que não era necessária
"nenhuma formação, educação ou
experiência especial",
que queria "operários,
funcionários públicos,
barbeiros, executivos,
balconistas, profissionais
liberais,
telefonistas, trabalhadores da
construção civil, vendedores,
trabalhadores de colarinho
branco, entre outros".
Quando as pessoas
responderam ao anúncio,
elas foram convidadas a
ir a um edifício
cujo exterior deve ser
familiar para vocês.
O edifício era o
Linsley-Chittenden Hall.
E quando elas entraram no prédio,
encontraram o estudo de um
cavalheiro que era assim:
O anúncio que eu acabei de
mostrar para vocês é, claro,
o anúncio recrutando indivíduos
para participar do famoso
estudo de Milgram.
Portanto, os participantes
preencheram o cupom do anúncio
e foram ao laboratório
que agora é o Linsley-Chittenden Hall.
A configuração do
edifício era diferente,
mas a fachada era grandiosa e o
laboratório era elegante.
Quando os indivíduos entraram no
laboratório, foram informados
que participariam de um estudo sobre
a aprendizagem e memória
em que podiam desempenhar 2 papéis.
Eles podiam ser o professor ou
podiam ser o aluno.
Mas, na realidade, quando tiravam os
pedaços de papel dobrados,
ambos diziam "professor",
e a outra pessoa,
que aparentemente tinha ido
participar do estudo,
era um colaborador.
Assim, quando o estudo foi realizado,
as pessoas que representaram o professor
eram 40 homens da área de New Haven
que responderam ao anúncio,
entre 20-50 anos,
com uma grande diversidade de
profissões e níveis de ensino.
E todos eles foram avisados que
participariam de uma tarefa
que envolvia testar o papel da
punição na aprendizagem
e que o 2º personagem, o "aluno",
era um contador de 47 anos
de origem irlandês-americana,
quase sempre descrito como
educado e simpático,
que seria apresentado a uma
série de palavras
e que a tarefa seria, simplesmente,
aplicar um choque elétrico ao "aluno"
cada vez que ele desse uma
resposta errada.
E, a fim de supervisionar o estudo,
havia uma 3ª pessoa presente
– o experimentador –, que era
um severo e impassível
professor de Biologia do ensino
médio, de 31 anos de idade.
Então, em cada caso,
2 figuras – o
experimentador e o aluno
–
foram as mesmas, e 1 figura, o
professor, variava.
A tarefa era a seguinte:
Eles eram apresentados a uma máquina
com uma série de interruptores que
começava com a etiqueta
"choque leve": 15 volts, 30
volts, 45 volts, 60 volts
e continuava em aumentos de 15:
75, 90, 105, 120 etc.
, até a etiqueta "choque
intenso": 255, 270, 285, 300,
"perigo de choque grave"
e, finalmente (não procurar
no Google!), "XXX".
Assim, cada um recebeu um choque
de 45 volts da máquina,
que a maioria estimou em 70 volts.
Ou seja, eles o sentiram
bastante intenso.
E, em seguida, eles foram
informados que precisariam aplicar
um choque ao aluno cada vez
que cometesse um erro.
Agora, antes de Milgram
conduzir este estudo,
ele entrevistou um grupo de
psicólogos de Yale
que fez previsões sobre
quantos choques os professores
estariam dispostos a dar.
E como vocês podem ver neste
gráfico, a previsão era de
que não mais que 3% dariam
choques no nível 20,
que está abaixo do nível de perigo,
e que praticamente ninguém iria
para o nível mais alto.
O que aconteceu, em vez disso, em
relação aos choques leves
(15, 30, 45, 60), foi que 100% dos
professores os aplicaram.
Quanto aos choques intensos
(255, 270, 285, 300),
88% dos indivíduos chegaram até lá.
Quando eles manifestaram uma
insatisfação em continuar,
o experimentador dizia: "Por
favor, continue",
ou "O experimento exige que
você continue",
ou "É absolutamente essencial
que você continue",
ou "Você não tem outra
escolha, deve continuar",
com nenhum outro estímulo fornecido.
No entanto, 68% dos indivíduos
continuaram até o nível
"perigo de choque grave"
e 65% seguiram até o último nível.
Esse patamar normalmente é enfatizado
quando as pessoas discutem sobre
o experimento de Milgram
e o fato extraordinário
sobre os seres humanos
investigados por Milgram,
uma vez que essa possibilidade
só tinha sido demonstrada
para o mundo do lado de fora
de um laboratório.
A pesquisa que Milgram conduziu foi
inspirada por uma tentativa
de entender o que poderia ter
explicado o comportamento
dos cidadãos alemães comuns
na Alemanha nazista.
Dito isso, o que eu quero elucidar
sobre o estudo de Milgram
é a parte da discussão posterior
ao que eu acabei de apresentar.
A discussão sobre como esses
indivíduos se sentiram, subjetivamente,
quando perpetraram um
comportamento doloroso em outro.
Como vocês podem ver a
partir deste slide,
isso foi feito por muitos deles.
A resposta psicológica dos
indivíduos soa como o que lemos
no livro de Jonathan Shay
para a última aula.
Muitos mostraram "sinais de nervosismo,
especialmente ao aplicar os
choques mais potentes.
Em grande número de casos, o
grau de tensão alcançou
extremos raramente observados em tais
indivíduos em laboratório.
Eles foram vistos suando,
gaguejando, mordendo os lábios,
gemendo, cravando as unhas
na própria carne."
Essas foram respostas recorrentes,
em vez de excepcionais.
E se alguém nunca viu o filme
realizado por Milgram
na condução dos experimentos – que
não são de domínio público,
mas que estão na internet –,
é possível ouvir a voz
calma do experimentador
e ver a agitação dos participantes.
Aqui está uma descrição:
"Eu poderia supor –
reporta Milgram –
que um sujeito se
abateria ou continuaria
de acordo com as ordens da
sua consciência.
Porém, isso está longe de
ser o que ocorreu.
Houve reações marcantes de
tensão e esforço emocional."
Um observador relatou:
"Eu vi um homem de negócios maduro
e equilibrado entrar no laboratório
sorridente e confiante.
20 minutos depois, ele foi
reduzido a espasmos e balbucios.
Ele puxava constantemente o
lóbulo da orelha.
Ele contorcia as mãos.
Em certo ponto, ele levou
o punho à testa
e murmurou: 'Oh Deus, parem com isso'
e, mesmo assim, continuou respondendo
a cada palavra do experimentador e
o obedeceu até o fim".
É uma coisa engraçada sobre
nós, criaturas humanas.
Que, por um lado, parece que
temos uma noção
do que podemos aguentar.
E, por outro lado, nós temos a
capacidade de ir além desse limite.
Essa capacidade pode ser explorada
para o bem ou para o mal.
Aqueles que estão em equipes
esportivas conhecem a experiência
de ser empurrado mais além
do que você pensou
que poderia ser o seu limite e se
surpreender executando algo que,
inicialmente, parecia impossível.
Mas são sempre as coisas pelas
quais sentimos repulsa
as que mais nos
surpreendemos executando.
No entanto, isso traz custos psíquicos.
E essa é a 2ª resposta para o
desafio de Glauco que eu quero dar
no contexto da aula sobre themis.
Quero voltar agora para o
tema da aula de hoje,
prosperidade e apego,
continuando com uma variação
dos estudos de Milgram.
Porque depois que Milgram
encontrou esses resultados
no seu trabalho de 1961, ele foi
tomado pela pergunta:
em que circunstâncias a
complacência foi maior ou menor?
Então, num estudo de
acompanhamento feito no ano
posterior,
Milgram explorou a questão na
sua forma mais geral.
Na sua forma mais geral, o
problema é o seguinte:
"Se X diz a Y para machucar Z,
em que condições Y
executará o comando de X
e em que condições ele recusará?
Na forma mais limitada possível em
pesquisas de laboratório,
a questão torna-se: se um
experimentador diz a um indivíduo
para machucar outra pessoa,
em que condições é que o
indivíduo cumprirá a instrução
e em que condições ele se
recusará a obedecer?"
Milgram propôs o teste
variando de modo contínuo
o grau de interação humana no estudo.
Numa série de estudos,
o experimentador, quem
dizia para continuar,
estava na sala com você,
no telefone com você
ou você só recebia
instruções escritas.
E a tendência dos indivíduos para
colaborar, para cooperar,
fazendo o que foi pedido a
eles, diminuiu diretamente
quando o pesquisador estava
presente na sala com eles.
Da mesma forma, Milgram variou na medida
que o indivíduo recebia feedback
da pessoa que estava sendo eletrocutada.
Será que eles não recebiam feedback,
chamada de condição remota?
Será que eles recebiam um
feedback de voz,
como nos experimentos iniciais,
em que se ouvia gritos
através da parede:
"É doloroso, eu estou
sofrendo, por favor, pare!"?
Será que eles estavam na sala com o
indivíduo, observando-o sofrer,
ou afinal, na condição mais extrema,
eles tinham de pegar o
braço do indivíduo,
colocá-lo numa placa de metal
e mantê-lo lá, para dar-lhe um choque?
O que Milgram descobriu é que,
embora a complacência
seja extremamente alta quando não
há feedback do sofredor,
ela é menor quando há feedback de voz,
menor ainda quando se está na sala
com a pessoa prejudicada
e menor ainda quando é você quem
tem de agir para causar danos.
Vocês se lembram da 1ª aula, a
aula de introdução,
quando eu comentei sobre
uma das questões
que discutiríamos este termo,
apresentando uma coisa chamada
"o problema do Trolley", um
caso em que um trem
está indo em direção a 5 pessoas.
E na 1ª versão desse estudo,
eu perguntei se seria moralmente
aceitável desviar o trem
de tal forma que ele fosse para um
trilho onde havia apenas 1 pessoa,
e a maioria de vocês pensou
que estava tudo bem.
Na 2ª variação do estudo,
eu perguntei se estaria bem,
para interromper o trem,
empurrar um homem gordo
que estava numa ponte sobre os trilhos.
E a maioria de vocês pensou que
isso NÃO estava bem.
Há algo na percepção humana
das nossas interações
com o outro que parece dar
origem à ansiedade
diante dos danos causados ??cujas
consequências nós vemos.
Milgram articula-a assim.
Ele diz: "Na remota e,
em menor medida, na condição
do feedback de voz,
o sofrimento da vítima possui
uma qualidade remota
e abstrata para o indivíduo.
Ele está consciente, mas apenas
num sentido conceitual."
A razão dele sabe, na
terminologia de Platão,
mas as outras partes da alma não
registraram o que está ocorrendo.
"Esse fenômeno – continua
Milgram – é normal.
Um soldado de bombarda pode imaginar
que as suas armas causarão
sofrimento e morte.
Na verdade, eles são tão
eficazes matando pessoas
como os soldados de infantaria.
Mas esse conhecimento é
desprovido de afeto
e não os faz sentir uma
resposta emocional
pelos sofrimentos de suas ações."
Observações semelhantes foram
feitas em tempos de guerra.
Dicas visuais associadas com o
sofrimento da vítima
desencadeiam respostas empáticas no
indivíduo e fornecem a ele
uma compreensão mais completa da
experiência da vítima.
E acontece que uma das principais
estratégias da Alemanha nazista
para ativar as pessoas a cometerem o
mal contra os seus vizinhos
era usar uma linguagem de
desumanização
em referência aos grupos prejudicados
(judeus, ciganos, homossexuais),
como não-humanos.
Quando percebemos o outro
como ser humano,
é difícil superar a tendência a
não querer prejudicá-lo.
E embora eu tenha dado um
número de exemplos
sobre como a resistência militar
pode ser um mecanismo poderoso
para perseguir a vontade de alguém,
o fato observado por Milgram
é, na verdade, o que
fundamenta a possibilidade
de outra forma de
resistência que tem sido,
em algumas circunstâncias,
surpreendentemente eficaz.
Aqui está Gandhi,
participando de protestos não-violentos
na Índia na década de 1940.
Aqui está uma manifestação
pacífica nas lanchonetes em Selma,
Alabama, em 1963.
E aqui, claro, uma das
imagens mais famosas
das últimas 2 décadas.
Um indivíduo parado sozinho
diante dos tanques,
detendo o curso deles até a
Praça da Paz Celestial.
Portanto, o que é isso
nos seres humanos
que faz com que seja mais
fácil evitar ordens
quando a pessoa que exige
não está presente
e mais difícil realizar ordens
quando estamos cara a cara com a pessoa
que está sendo prejudicada?
Bem, isso nos seres humanos é o
fato surpreendente que somos,
profundamente, entidades sociais.
Somos entidades sociais
de uma forma contínua aos nossos
ancestrais primatas não-humanos.
Portanto, Harry Harlow, na 1ª
metade do século 20,
realizou uma série de estudos
utilizando primatas não-humanos
para tentar descobrir qual é o
papel da conexão emocional
e do vínculo social
desempenhado na prosperidade.
Nos famosos estudos da mãe de
arame vs. mãe de pano,
os macacos foram apresentados a 2 seres
com os quais eles poderiam
passar o tempo.
A mãe de arame tinha leite
e eles precisavam ir até ela
para conseguir comida,
mas a mãe de pano tinha conforto e,
se eles queriam ser consolados,
precisavam ir até ela.
E macaco após macaco fez o que
vocês veem nesta foto.
Foram... e o fato de vocês
estarem dizendo "Aaah"
é uma evidência forte.
Nós achamos isso adorável.
Achamos que... na verdade, é
muito difícil controlar
os músculos da face ao ver esta imagem.
Certo?
Todos nós estamos olhando para ela,
vendo esses olhos grandes,
essa expressão de afeto.
É parte da experiência de
maturação primata que,
para se tornar um membro saudável
e próspero da espécie,
o contato social precoce é fundamental.
E, de fato,
alguns dos estudos mais moralmente
problemáticos de Harlow
envolveram sujeitar os macacos jovens
à privação social completa,
descobrindo mais tarde que ao
saírem da privação,
o comportamento deles era
incompatível com a vida em
comunidade.
Eles não só eram hostis e
agressivos com os seus pares,
mesmo com os seus filhos,
como eram incapazes de se
engajar em carinho.
Então é possível imaginar, como
fizeram o aluno de Harlow,
John Bowlby, e a sua
colaboradora, Mary Ainsworth,
se existe algo fundamental
para os seres humanos
prosperarem que pode ser
aprendido com a imagem que vemos
do experimento de Harlow.
Ou seja, é possível que, para o
desenvolvimento dos seres humanos,
precisemos de um certo tipo de calor e
interação que não se limita
apenas ao recebimento de nutrientes
necessários para a maturação
por meio de uma mãe de arame?
Eu tirei este próximo slide de um site
chamado "Positive Parenting",
porque eu quero que vocês
reconheçam o quanto a imagem
que Bowlby e Ainsworth promoveram
permeou as concepções
contemporâneas de como é
conveniente um pai para as crianças.
Mary Ainsworth trouxe
crianças de cerca de 2 anos
para um ambiente de laboratório,
juntamente com o seu cuidador principal.
E a pergunta que ela queria
verificar era o quão confortável
as crianças estariam numa
situação estranha, uma situação
em que elas seriam obrigadas a
administrar por conta própria,
longe do seu cuidador, a fim de
brincar com alguns brinquedos.
Com base nisso, ela identificou 3
– isso foi agora ampliado para 4 –
3 estilos de apego que as crianças
podem ter com os seus cuidadores.
O 1º, o apego seguro,
é resultado da experiência da
1ª infância, que envolve
a capacidade de resposta previsível
para as nossas necessidades
por alguém que sente afeto por você.
Se você está com fome, alguém
responde fornecendo alimento.
Se você sente dor, alguém
responde confortando a sua dor.
Se você está com frio, alguém
responde aquecendo-o.
E tudo isso é feito de tal forma
que você começa a formar uma
impressão de si mesmo
como um agente no mundo cuja
expressão das necessidades
e desejos pode indicar em outros
seres conscientes respostas
que refletem o que você
precisa e deseja.
O mundo se torna um lugar em que a
confiança social é possível
e os 1º instintos que
você venha a ter,
quando apresentado a rostos e
corpos da mesma espécie,
faz com que, mais tarde, o seu
padrão de resposta mais primitivo
tenha uma expectativa de que, se
não há prova contrária,
o membro da mesma espécie
será sensível
às suas necessidades
honestas e expressas.
Por outro lado, uma porcentagem
menor de crianças apresentaram
o que Ainsworth chamou de
apego evitativo.
Elas não estavam dispostas
a explorar a sala
e não estavam dispostas a isso,
segundo a hipótese de Ainsworth,
porque a sua experiência
na 1ª infância
tinha sido com um cuidador
desinteressado ou distante.
Diante da expressão de necessidade,
não havia sentido se havia
um outro social,
se esse outro social vai responder
ao que você está pedindo.
Portanto, há um sentido
desenvolvido onde o mundo
não é um lugar seguro e cooperativo.
O 3º grupo eram as crianças que ela
chamou de apego ambivalente.
Crianças com apego ambivalente
experimentavam um regime
de resposta que, por vezes, estava de
acordo com o que elas pediam
e, por vezes, ignorava-as por completo.
Assim, apesar de não terem a sensação
de que o mundo nunca fazia
o que se pedia,
elas tinham a sensação de que o mundo
não fazia de forma confiável o
que se pedia para elas.
E, por último, numa 4ª
categoria adicionada depois,
estão as crianças que não são
apenas ignoradas, mas que são,
de fato, abusadas ou maltratadas diante
da expressão de necessidade.
Agora, essa taxonomia não tem
um nível de precisão
que aponta facilmente em qual
categoria está cada criança
como resultado do seu tratamento.
Há muitas questões sobre as
disposições inatas
que as crianças têm e há muitos
casos em que não há clareza
sobre como colocar as
crianças nesta taxonomia.
No entanto, ela serviu como base de
um dos estudos científicos
mais extraordinários feitos
no século passado,
um estudo longitudinal de 30
anos, conduzido por pessoas
que tomaram a sério a teoria do apego,
que analisaram a que preditores de
prosperidade subsequente
poderia ser atribuída à
experiência da 1ª infância.
E este livro, The Development of the
Person (que eu li durante o verão),
é extraordinário no sentido de
mostrar o que é preciso
para estabelecer uma hipótese
científica social complicada,
mesmo com um grau razoável de certeza.
Porque, é claro, se quisermos saber
mais sobre se a experiência
da 1ª infância afeta o
desenvolvimento posterior,
não podemos usar vocês,
afinal nós perdemos
a nossa máquina do tempo.
Nós a deixamos no futuro.
Não podemos voltar e ver como
foram as infâncias de vocês.
Todos esses estudos precisaram ser
feitos de forma prospectiva.
Então o que este grupo fez foi
estudar centenas de crianças,
com o incrível esforço de segui-las,
mesmo quando elas se mudaram para longe.
E a conclusão básica que
eles chegaram...
o livro tem várias
centenas de páginas...
a conclusão básica que eles chegaram
confirma a hipótese da teoria do apego.
Essa experiência da 1ª infância e,
em especial, a experiência da
infância no início de uma relação
responsiva e de confiança,
molda significativamente
os padrões posteriores de
resposta para o mundo.
Mas, claro, já ouvimos
falar disso antes.
Quando nos disseram que "não é
sem importância adquirir
um tipo de hábito ou outro
desde a juventude.
Na verdade, é muito importante."
Agora, nada disso quer dizer
que aqueles cujas
experiências da 1ª
infância
não foram ideal nunca vão prosperar.
O espírito humano é extremamente
resistente e é possível,
por meio de certos tipos de
interação terapêutica
ou certos tipos de cultivo de outras
relações de confiança,
superar a privação da 1ª infância.
Mas há um caminho mais
fácil para prosperar
e é o que passa pela
confiança na 1ª infância.
Agora, o fato de os seres
humanos serem seres sociais
nos afeta não apenas no início da
vida, mas também no final.
"Se você quer prever –
destaca Jonathan Haidt –
o quão feliz é alguém, ou quanto
tempo ela está propensa a viver,
você deve verificar as suas
relações sociais.
Ter fortes relações sociais
fortalece o sistema imunológico.
Isso estende a vida mais do
que parar de fumar.
Isso acelera a
recuperação de uma
cirurgia,
reduz o risco de
depressão e ansiedade".
As interações sociais
são fundamentais
para o desenvolvimento humano.
E isso não é uma descoberta
apenas do ocidente.
Aqui estão alguns títulos de artigos
retirados do Google Scholar
quando eu estava fazendo o meu
exercício dirigido:
"Efeitos da Integração Social: Na
preservação da função
da memória na população
idosa dos EUA".
Aqui está um sobre o índice de
sobrevivência das amizades
na sociedade australiana.
Aqui está um sobre a integração
social e mortalidade na França.
Aqui está um sobre a interação
social e mortalidade na Suécia.
Aqui está um da Finlândia. Aqui está um
do Japão. Aqui está um da China.
Em todas as culturas,
o engajamento social é fundamental
para a prosperidade humana.
Agora, nós podemos querer
perguntar se isso diz alguma coisa
sobre a questão que estamos
interessados ??neste segmento do curso
– a questão da
prosperidade humana –
e se isso nos diz algo sobre as
questões que abordaremos
nas unidades subsequentes do
curso: as nossas discussões
sobre a moralidade e as nossas
discussões de filosofia política.
Harrow, Bowlby e Ainsworth e o
estudo de Minnesota
apontaram que, para os seres humanos
desenvolverem o tipo de
relações de confiança
que permite a uma sociedade
decolar, é crucial
que haja um certo tipo de conexão
social estável na infância.
Vamos perguntar, no contexto
de nossa discussão
sobre a filosofia política, se
isso tem alguma implicação
na forma como a sociedade
deve ser estruturada
se queremos cultivar cidadãos justos
capazes de participação
nacional e democrática.
Será que isso significa que
algo que pensávamos
não ter nenhum interesse na
conjuntura da filosofia política
– a estrutura interna da família –,
sim que interessa a filosofia política?
E se for assim, isso significa uma
vitória para a esquerda?
Para a direita?
Para algo completamente diferente?
Vamos perguntar
– no contexto da discussão de
Haidt sobre o amor romântico
como uma combinação
extraordinária da nossa
capacidade
de apego, de cuidar e de
união em par –
se qualquer código moral que
devemos respeitar abraça o fato
de que ter relações especiais com
determinados indivíduos
nos torna incapazes de
tratá-los como um entre muitos,
apesar da moralidade parecer nos exigir
um tratamento igual para todos.
Vamos perguntar
– no contexto da discussão
de Nozick sobre o amor
como uma formação de um nós –
se quando formamos
conexões que ultrapassam
as conexões dos indivíduos
em coisas como bairros
ou comunidades religiosas ou nações,
isso tem alguma influência
moral ou política.
Vamos voltar à questão
levantada por Stockdale:
Ele destacou a importância
da amizade, da união
e da camaradagem na resistência
diante do sofrimento;
se, de fato, compete às
estruturas políticas
promover a estabilidade nas
comunidades, de modo a permitir
que as pessoas resistam às
intempéries do destino.
E com isso, vamos ser capazes de
dar sentido a esse fenômeno
extraordinariamente estranho que é a
Ética a Nicômaco de Aristóteles,
um livro sobre ética que fundamenta
a tradição ética ocidental,
incluindo entre os seus 12 capítulos,
2 capítulos inteiros dedicados
à questão da amizade,
em que Aristóteles começa
por salientar que,
se você é jovem ou é velho,
se é rico ou é pobre,
se está num momento da sua vida
em que as coisas vão bem
ou num momento em que as
coisas vão mal,
nada desempenha um papel mais central
no que permite a você
prosperar que a amizade.
Obrigada a todos vocês por terem
vindo a esta aula adicional.
Estou feliz de que haja perguntas,
embora, tecnicamente, chegamos ao fim
dos 50 minutos que tínhamos.
Mas eu estou feliz em respondê-las,
afinal não há limite de tempo.
Olá, sim...
Estudante: [inaudível]
Profª. Tamar Gendler: Não,
as pessoas podem sair!
Faça a sua pergunta.
Eu adoraria respondê-la.
Estudante: [inaudível] entre o
carinho na 1ª infância,
que leva a prosperar, e a
negligência, que levaria a algo
ruim.
Mas isso parece estar
moralmente carregado,
há um juízo de valor
inerente em tudo isso.
E eu estive pensando, porque eu
acho que o livro mencionado
sobre as diferentes facetas da nossa
personalidade [ininteligível]
experiência porque não podemos
dizer que necessariamente
há uma boa maneira de saber
como educar o seu filho.
Profª. Tamar Gendler: OK...
Então a pergunta era...
Veja bem, eu declarei que um certo
carinho na 1ª infância
parece conduzir a capacidades
sociais de um determinado tipo,
enquanto a negligência
parece conduzir a deficiências sociais.
Ao fazer essa afirmação,
A) será que estou fazendo um juízo
de valor que é ilegítimo
sobre como queremos ser capazes de
funcionar em sociedade?
B) será que estou fazendo um juízo
de valor que é ilegítimo
sobre o que é apropriado na
criação dos filhos?
Deixa eu responder a 2ª antes...
As declarações sobre o
carinho na 1ª infância
feitas aqui são, principalmente, sobre
os primeiros 18 meses de
vida mais ou menos.
Há grande controvérsia aqui no
campus, e em outros lugares,
sobre o que é apropriado depois
dos 18 meses iniciais.
Mas parece haver evidência muito clara,
tanto a nível nacional
quanto intercultural,
que durante os primeiros 18 meses
a ideia de muito carinho,
de muita resposta,
é a ideia plausível.
Ou seja, ter as suas
necessidades atendidas
parece ser uma forma de promover a
estabilidade e confiança.
OK. De volta à 1ª pergunta...
será que estamos fazendo juízos
de valor sobre o que é
ser uma boa pessoa quando dizemos:
estamos buscando cultivar em nós a
possibilidade de confiança
e de conexão em vez de uma
vida de desconfiança?
Imagino que haja circunstâncias,
sociedades em que ser de
confiança seja uma desvantagem.
Ser capaz de responder a alguém
sem estar constantemente em
guarda seja perigoso.
E, nessas circunstâncias, talvez
faça sentido cultivar
um tipo diferente de
experiência de 1ª infância.
Se isso mostra que nós encontramos
2 formas igualmente boas
de prosperidade, é algo que vamos falar
quando entrarmos no relativismo
moral daqui a algumas semanas.
Bom. Obrigada.